Yeah, man. So, I've been waiting to come
on the stage for a while, but I didn't
know how to get on on the link. Yeah.
So, it's nice to be nice to talk to you
because I've been watching you for for a
while now.
>> Uh yeah. So, basically, I disagree about
uh you know, the whole um idea
that uh Jesus is God and is a part of
um a union with with Yeah. I have a
trinity union with the with the the
father and the holy spirit.
>> Okay.
>> What do you believe? You believe you
believe
>> he's in.
>> You don't know who I thought he said he
was Jewish.
>> He is. But he don't
>> you believe only God is one person,
right, Ben?
>> Yeah. Yeah. But without the the other
persons.
>> Okay. Have we spoken before?
>> No.
>> No,
>> we haven't. This is the first time.
>> All right. All right. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Let me show you something, man. I want
to get your thoughts on something.
>> So, we're going to look at this verse of
Genesis 28. Is that cool?
>> You familiar with Jacob's dream?
>> Not not [clears throat] so much.
>> Okay. So, all right. So, it says here in
Genesis 28, we'll start at verse 10.
It says, "Jacob left Beersa and went
toward Haron, and he came to a certain
place and stayed there that night
because the sun had set. Taking one of
the stones of the place, he put it under
his head and laid down in that place to
sleep. And he dreamed, and behold, there
was a ladder set up on the earth, and
the top of it reached to heaven. And
behold, the angels of God were ascending
and descending on it.
And behold,
the Lord stood above it, or Yahweh stood
above it, and said,"I am the Lord, the
God of Abraham, your father, and the God
of Isaac. The land on which you lie, I
will give to you and your offspring.
Your offspring shall be like the dust of
the earth, and you shall spread abroad
to the west, and to the east, north, and
south. And in you and your offspring
shall all the families of the earth be
blessed. Behold, I am with you and will
keep you wherever you go and will bring
you back to this land. Now, this is this
is important. He's going to be with him
wherever he goes and will bring him back
to this land. He'll keep him, right? For
I will not I will not leave you until I
have done what I have promised you.
[snorts]
So, does this sound familiar? You
familiar with the story?
>> No, this doesn't sound familiar, but I
don't see anything suspicious there.
>> Okay. So God appeared to a to Jacob in a
dream and told him and made a covenant
with him and said that he's going to
make him fruitful and multiply him and
he's going to keep him always until he
fulfills his promise. Right.
>> Surely.
>> Okay. And then um so watch this. Then
Jacob awoke from his sleep and said,
"Surely the Lord is in this place and I
did not know it." And he was afraid and
said, "How awesome is this place? This
is none other than the house of God, and
this is the gate of heaven. So early in
the morning, Jacob took the stone that
he had put under his head and set it up
for a pillar and poured oil on top of
it. He called the name of this of that
place Bethl, but the name of the city
was L at first. Then Jacob made a vow,
saying, "If God will be with me and will
keep me in this way that I go, and
will give me bread to eat, clothing to
wear, so that I come again to my
father's house in peace. Then Yahweh
shall be my God, and this stone which I
have set up for a pillar shall be God's
house, and of all that you give me, I
will give a full tent to you." All
right. So then we see Jacob makes a vow
after seeing the Lord in his dream. He
then makes a vow to God that he will
serve him and follow him forever, right?
As long as he protects him and keeps
him.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Cool.
>> All right. So now I want to just go a
few chapters ahead.
So Jacob sees him in a dream. Now let's
go to Genesis 31.
and we're going to do uh [snorts]
about 10 to 14
>> Genesis 31. Right.
>> That's right.
>> Okay. I'll just I'll open it in the you
know there's going to be some u
discrepancy between the translations and
the and the [clears throat]
interpretations of the translations,
right? We we can already agree about
that.
>> Do you read Hebrew?
>> Yeah, I am. Uh, that's my native
language.
>> Good. So, then we could just pull up the
Hebrew and you could just double check
for us to make sure.
>> No, I don't mind. You can whatever you
want. You can stick with the English. I
I got the the Hebrew open here. Whatever
you want. Yeah, I don't mind.
>> Okay.
>> What What um what line?
>> So, we're going to read verse 11 to for
to uh to 13.
>> Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, I'm with you.
>> You're with me?
>> Awesome.
>> All right. So, it says, "Then the angel
of God said to me in the dream." So, the
angel of the Lord came to Jacob in a
dream.
>> Jacob, and I said, "Here I am." And he
said, "Lift up your eyes and see all the
goats that mate with the flock are
striped, spotted, and modeled, for I
have seen all that Laban is doing to
you." So the angel of the Lord comes to
him in a dream and says, and is talking
to him, correct? Telling him that he
sees everything that's happening to him.
Right?
>> Now, the angel of the Lord continues. He
says, "I am the God of Bethl, where you
anointed a pillar and made a vow to me.
Now arise, go out from this land and
return to the land of your kindred."
>> So the angel of God here
claims to be God himself.
>> Sure.
>> What is your understanding here? If
there is no trinity, how does this make
sense?
>> I mean, if I mean, according to Okay, so
I'll try to answer it from this perspect
perspective. [clears throat] According
to our tradition, uh the angels are
basically like um like robots, you know,
so they don't they don't have any will.
They don't have any um yeah any any
will. So they're determined. So
on this logic for for um an angel to
come to Jacob and talk to him and to say
I come to you in the name of the Lord,
this just doesn't make any sense because
he's determined to do so. So this is by
the way um almost anywhere where where
where it says that um
um even where it says Elohim where it
says only God came and talked and walked
or or whatever it it refers to an angel
of of God.
>> So I think I hope I answered your your
question.
>> So this is you're you're you're close
actually. It's interesting. Do you
wanted to say something there? No, my my
camera's
>> like what's he raising his head for?
[laughter]
Um, yeah. So, so you're actually you're
you're kind of you're kind of right and
and there is also something that's wrong
as well because you're familiar with
Daniel and how Daniel an angel came to
Daniel. Correct.
>> Um, I'm not that familiar about those,
you know, the specific stories in the
Bible. I guess as you right I'll give
you that that credit though.
>> Okay. So an angel came to Daniel
and spoke to him and told him that he's
a messenger from God to give him the
word that God had delivered to him. But
there was an incident happening. The
angel was slow getting to Daniel because
he was fighting a demonic entity on his
way there. He was fighting an unclean
spirit. Um, and then Michael the
archangel had to come and help him, help
Gabriel. You're familiar with Gabriel
the angel, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So, the Gabriel we're talking
about. So, Gabriel was [snorts] on his
way to deliver God's message to Daniel,
but was halted. Needed Michael to come
help him. And then he was able to
continue on his mission to go uh talk to
Daniel. And when he comes to Daniel, he
tells him that he has found favor in the
Lord and that God has um has seen him
and that God has blessed him. He doesn't
say, "I have seen you and I have blessed
you." But he refers back to God. You
see, you understand what I'm saying? You
understand where I'm getting at?
>> Yeah. The same example. Yeah. Where
Yeah. Now the difference with this angel
of the Lord here, the angel of God here,
this particular messenger, he doesn't
say this is what God said. He doesn't
say I've come to give you a message from
God. He says I am God. He says I have
seen what has been done to you. He says
I'm the one who you made the vow to at
Bethl. I am the God of your father
Abraham and Isaac.
So there's a difference with how the
angel of the Lord, he speaks and he
introduces himself and he um you know
responds versus how the other angels
will see in the scripture how they act
and how they respond.
>> Uh I don't see the I don't see
the problem here also because it's like
when uh when it says that God wrestled
with with Jacob, right?
>> Yeah. [snorts]
So we also u we also uh view that as a
reference to um I mean
>> the angel the angel of the lord right?
>> Yeah it's an angel which wrestled with
him.
>> Yeah but notice it's it's always the
angel of the lord it's it's a particular
angel of the lord who claims and who
other prophets recognize to be god. They
even offer they even offer sacrifices to
him.
Wait, I didn't see you make that uh that
uh distinction or you you present that
distinction. Where do you see that that
there's a specific angel which it always
uh you know
>> Yeah. So notice how you see the angel of
the Lord here and he's never even named.
There's a there's a time where they ask
his name and he says why do you ask my
name for it's too wonderful. Right? But
the other angels, a few of them, we we
when they interact, we get their names.
We get Gabriel's name. We get Michael's
name, right? This angel says, "My name's
too wonderful.
It's too wonderful. It's too magnificent
for you to comprehend." And this he he
continuously shows up. This particular
angel continues to show up. He delivers
the Israelites out of the out of Egypt,
splits the sea. He comes to Abraham and
comes to Jacob and says, "I'm the God of
of the covenant and I'm the one that you
made a vow to and I'm going to make you
a great nation. I'm going to multiply
you, you and your offspring." This is
the angel of the Lord claiming this,
saying that that's me. I said that,
right? Coming to Moses saying, "I am the
God of I Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob."
That's the Remember, it's the angel of
the Lord that appeared to Moses in the
midst of the bush. It says
>> okay
>> so this particular angel this particular
messenger is not a mere spiritual
creature like the others he is a divine
figure who is God himself who acts as a
messenger and a revealer of God as well
>> wait what what tell me this what's the
difference between God coming in the
form of an angel or coming in the form
of anything and talk to Jacob, Moses,
and whatever or God sending an angel to
do that. That what's the difference
there? I mean, it's all God, right? He's
>> Well, well, no. There there's a big
difference. So, the big difference is is
one, it would be God himself coming and
speaking, right?
>> But it's all God himself. Everything is
God himself. It's not if if God sends
like when God sends Moses to speak,
Moses is speaking on God's behalf,
right?
>> Okay.
>> But but if if God didn't use Moses, he
said, "No, forget Moses. I'm going to
come and speak myself." That's a big
difference. If God comes himself and
speaks on his own behalf, that's
different from him sending a, you know,
an agent to speak on his behalf to
represent him. But but on this on this
example, Moses is a human, right?
>> And um a human with a will. So it
already has a personal um personality.
He's already a person by himself. So why
>> the angels?
>> Yeah. But not not according to us. Like
the angels are basically robots. They
they don't have
>> Yeah. But where do you where do you get
that from that angels are basically
robots? Because
>> uh we we we see in the scriptures that
the angels didn't like in Job it talks
about the the angels rejoicing at God's
creation,
>> right?
>> Mention the angels that fell too if
they're robots. It would make no sense
why any angels fell.
>> Sorry. Say again.
>> Said and the fact that angels also fell
according to the Old Testament. So it
wouldn't make any sense for them to be
robots if they fell from God.
>> If they fell. What do you mean if they
failed
>> that they rebelled against God with
Satan? Do you believe do you hold to
that
>> Okay. Where is that exactly? Because
that that definitely go against
>> that definitely go against the the whole
idea that they are robots. But where is
that
>> point? Yeah. All right. Let's go to it.
>> All right. [clears throat]
Uh we can go to let's see
Isaiah 14 is one of them. Um Isaiah 14
chapter 12 or Isaiah 14 verse 12-15 says
how you are fallen from heaven oh day
star son of dawn. How you are cut to the
ground you who laid the nations low. You
said in your heart I will ascend into
the heaven above the stars of the god. I
will set my throne on high. I will sit
on the mount of the assembly in the far
reaches of the north. I will ascend
above the heights of the clouds. I will
make myself like the most high, but you
brought down the shield to the far the
reaches of the pit.
So, if they're robots, how does this
occur?
>> Yeah, that's that's that's a good that's
a good point.
>> Mhm.
>> So, they had they had a choice to either
continue to follow and obey and love God
or to rebel against him, which led to
their fall.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's no Yeah.
There's no argument there. I I just
>> I need also to make sure where I where
we have the the the idea that angels are
robots, which for me would make the most
logical logical sense, right? Because
>> not with the scripture would you'd have
to conscious.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But sure, but yeah. So, so
according to so I mean my opinion is
that uh there are some um logical
contradiction. So, so for for my
opinion, it's not it's not 100% from
God, you know, like the Torah, the
Torah, the the the the Bible. I know
it's not a con it's not um conventional
opinion amongst um
believers in in Judaism, but
>> Uhhuh. That was kind
>> What kind of Jew are you?
>> Sorry.
>> What kind of Jew? I don't know. A Jew. I
don't know what kind.
How do you How do you Can you real fast?
Can you just make sure? Can you Can you
just say Muhammad's a false prophet for
us real fast?
Now,
>> I'm not Muslim at all, man. I'm not
Muslim at all.
>> Can you say that for us, man? Just to
make sure.
>> Yeah. According to my belief, Muhammad
is not a prophet.
>> All right. So, to make sure, bro, cuz it
sounded very Islamic to me. I don't know
about you, logic.
>> No, I mean,
the Torah
>> Wait, wait, wait. Let's do Wait, wait,
wait, wait. that okay so angels are
robot but right so
>> no
>> like I said at the beginning I have a
lot of stuff that I agree with you so
it's also that I have a lot of stuff
that I agree with Muslims but I also
disagree a lot with them
>> right and I think it's
>> so so let's let's get to the let's let's
continue on this nitty-gritty so we we
know that from the scripture that the
angels are not um they they they have
free will they can think and they have
feelings and they have a will they rebel
held against God and fell, right? Um
what's what's your idea on on on Satan?
Do you believe Satan was is a fallen
angel?
>> It's the same
>> it's the same thing to me. Yeah. To
according to my own belief and I believe
it is I'm 95% believe that this is the
the conception amongst Jew Jish people
that the devil is also a robot. It it
>> it doesn't have any any will, right? It
does. But by the way, according [snorts]
to Jew Judaism,
He has no
>> when God
>> when God create according to to rabbitic
Judaism when God created the devil which
God created the devil it it was the he
was very happy. He was more happy when
he created the other um creation because
only with the evil you can get good.
Only with the evil you can get um
>> huh some someone get get tested.
>> That's not true bro. Oh Lord how you
think your God was happy with the evil?
Oh Lord have mercy.
>> I mean he created it. You think that God
didn't create the devil?
>> What the devil is an angel?
>> What?
>> We're getting we're get we're getting
too too far off of this stuff, man.
>> Uh bro, so look with what we've seen,
man. You you cannot there cannot be good
or evil without your your your choice,
without your free will. You [snorts]
can't if you're programmed to if you're
programmed to sin, you're you're not h
you're not making a choice to do evil.
You're not making a choice to sin. If
you're programmed to sin, it's really
not sin. It's just an illusion. Then
it's not really evil. Evil comes with
with your choices. Goodness comes with
your choices. You can choose to love or
choose to to be selfish and hate and
rebel. That's
>> Wait, you're saying that the devil is
not the devil? Uh,
>> the devil rebelled against the devil
rebelled against God, man.
>> Yeah. I don't see how that how that how
that makes sense, bro. Because God
created the devil and and and
>> Okay. So, do you what what do you So,
let me ask you this then because cuz
like we're we're like in the weeds right
now. Like this is this is insane.
For do you believe that that the devil
rebelled against God or not?
>> No. According to my belief, the devil
does his part.
>> So why he does his job?
>> Was the devil kicked out of heaven?
>> No. I mean, I I I'm not sure about that
specific, you know. But
>> did the devil deceive Eve and Adam in
the in the Garden of Eden?
>> Yeah, but he was he was created to do
so.
>> No, bro. That's that's Islam.
>> Yeah, that's the whole point. I mean,
what how could
>> that's Islam. Islam teaches that that
Allah
>> bro like I said predestined Adam to to
sin 40 years before his creation. But
that's that's not the Torah, brother.
The Torah, good and evil is your choice.
That's your choice. The devil.
>> Okay. So,
>> did did God punish the serpent for
deceiving Eve?
>> God punished the serpent? Yeah.
According to the story, Yeah. So why
would so why would God punish the
serpent for doing something that God
orchestrated him to do in the
>> because some of it some of it some of it
is is is is
a metaphor like I said in the beginning
there there are some logical
contradictions right some of it is is
metaphor let me ask you that let's say
let's say God let's say God created
God created everything right but
>> hey brother this um
>> this I I think that We we can't really
we can't really build off of anything
because I I thought that you you said
you're a Jew. I thought that you took
the the scriptures as they are, but then
you're like you're picking and choosing
what you what you say has really
happened or what is a metaphor and stuff
like that. So,
>> fair enough. I'm not I'm not uh I'm not
con I'm not orthodox, right?
>> Clearly that wasn't that healing. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Sure.
>> But but it's it's all good, man. I'm I'm
gonna give somebody else a chance to
come up. I do appreciate your time, man,
and engaging with us. I appreciate it.
>> Yeah, man. It was lovely to be here.
I'll continue listening. Yeah.
>> All right.
>> Maybe next time if you if you want to.
>> All right, too.
>> We got Protestant Jews in here. [snorts]
>> Wow.
>> That was a thing.
>> Really? Protestant Jews?
>> That's what it seemed like, huh?
>> That's what we No,
no, no, not at all. Using Protestant
Protestants as a as a as a as a as a
shot. No, not a shot. I was Protestant,
bro. I love Protestant.
>> I was. Look at you. Look at you was.
>> Yeah. You gonna be was too in like a
year from now. [laughter]
>> [gasps]